wo ist dein weg
ich hätte gerne diese datteln das sind
300 gramm dafür sonst noch etwas sein
zwar nahmen vielleicht sind im angebot
ein kilo bananen kostet 1 euro 10 oder
äpfel ein kilo für eine 75 sehr gut sehr
günstig ich hätte gerne einen von
tomaten und drei gruppen wie viel kosten
wie gurken kosten heute 90 cent das
stück
oder sind in fünf stück für vier euro
ich nehme fünf gruppen sehr gute wahl
die sind ganz frisch was kosten die
tomaten 1 von tomaten kostet zwei euro
oder 3 und für 5 eur 991 und so nico ich
glaube wir haben dann alles oder
ich muss noch bezahlen wie viel kostet
alles zusammen 300 gramm datteln fünf
gurken und einen von tomaten das macht
12 40
20 euro vielen dank und 67 zurück
hier die beiden orangen schenke ich
ihnen